first off before we get into anything
here i have to tell you because of this
roe v wade thing i walk into the studio
today and sitting on my desk one of my
guys printed this out for me and just
left it on my desk there is clarence
thomas
today is obviously a very good day for
him and people that like him yesterday
was his birthday so it almost happened
on his birthday but we got to start with
uh roe v wade being reversed got a
little something from town hall to kick
us off here breaking the supreme court
has overturned roe v wade returning
abortion law to the states and libby
since you're joining us today we often
source the post-millennial uh but we did
it for you today uh the supreme court on
wednesday released a ruling in the case
of friday jackson
oh
right friday why does that say wednesday
that's an error on post millennial we
just copied and pasted it uh yeah we
just copy and pasted the supreme court
on friday released a ruling in the case
of dobbs vs jackson women's health
organization they have overturned roe v
wade which legalized abortion at the
federal level at issue in the case was
whether all restrictions to abortion
prior to viability are constitutional or
not the decision a draft of which was
which was leaked in late april
essentially overturns the landmark 1973
ruling in roe v wade that federally
legalized abortion now the decision on
whether or not abortion is legal returns
to the states so broadly speaking i
think we're all somewhat like-minded on
this and that we're states rights people
we don't like government overreach and
we do like personal choice uh jeffrey i
want to start with you here uh since i
know that so much what i just said there
is in your pedigree it's in your blood
uh i sense you look at this as a good
day
i'm glad it came out this summer rather
than waiting closer to the election my
own prediction is that this whole thing
is going to be not a big existential
threat to privacy and human rights and
everything else all it does is devolve
it to the states
and the states that have liberal laws
now will continue to have liberal laws
those that have tighter laws will
continue to have tighter laws it takes
the battle back to the states and i
think everybody's going to calm down
pretty soon i would give it to in two
months we'll realize that's not the end
of the world the decision is right and
we can put this as a national issue
behind us and i will be very relieved
for that
wait jeffrey are you telling me you're
not predicting a summer of peace and uh
tranquility when the riots are coming
and they're burning cities down and cns
cnn is telling us that it's all in the
name of tolerance and diversity yeah i
don't i don't believe anything that's
going to happen i think it's a little
bit of but the shock already happened
with the leak right i mean that already
people that we have went through about
48 hours of freak out and there'll be
more of that in light of this decision
but i think everything's going to calm
down and people realize that it's a it's
a state-level battle the battle will
continue in every state and and things
will settle down and we'll go back to
the system we've had should have had
from the very beginning this whole issue
should have been regulated by the states
according to the constitutional
structure it was inevitable if we have a
supreme court that takes the
constitution seriously that at some
point roe v wade is going to be
overturned
and and
that's in the name of social peace
this is this is the right way i think it
should have happened a very long time
ago
and as i say i think we're going to have
a patchwork of laws all over the country
and unfortunately the thing that's vexed
us for all these decades which is this
national abortions uh abortion rights
struggle can just go go to the states
and you can pick your state
and and some will have liberal laws some
uh tighter
and and we'll move on as a country
that's that's the way the american
system is supposed to function and i i
think i think we're going to find that
we're okay with it i think our people on
all sides are going to be okay with it
right i'm going to disagree i'm going to
go ahead and disagree let's go
look i mean i completely agree with you
in terms of where
we should be as a country
and um and yes of course and i agree
that the ruling was was was properly
decided and also that
the original roe v wade ruling
disfigured politics about this issue
for the last 50 years but i don't think
there's any hope of sort of going back
to normal and uh and and uh and like
okay everybody embrace federalism now
because the left is built um it's it's
it's
conception of government
um in opposition to federalism their
their answer for this is not okay well
you know we lost here which means we'll
just have to suck it up and uh
and and and offer unlimited abortions in
blue states i mean yes they will do that
but um but they're the the the rationale
for their um their entire program falls
apart if they cannot get this done at a
federal level they want everything done
at a federal level so i think what's
going to happen now is is these the
rhetoric is going to be dialed up
because they understand their their
their their activist base is is smart
enough or at least that the democrats in
power let's say are smart enough to
understand that this isn't about
abortion
as much as it's about their entire suite
of issues and really the way they wield
power the way they conceive of
their wielding of power through the
administrative state so i think what's
going to happen now is they're going to
go full bore to try to uh to pack the
court
in addition to all kinds of
administrative you know fixes as you
suggested on the on the on the state and
local level
but they're going to be putting up a
fight everywhere there is no shortage of
money you know i mean they i think uh
you know lefty uh nonprofits and pacs
and and and and sort of all this stuff
even even dark money groups which the
left has everybody's gonna be positioned
to to uh to push this because i think
they understand exactly how much of a
threat this is to their entire program
so it's interesting it's interesting
because i sense before libby jumps in i
since we're all probably in agreement on
the idea that there was no federally
constitutional guaranteed right to an
abortion it's simply not in the
constitution so i think most people can
understand that regardless of whether
you have a personal uh feeling that you
should allow abortions for a certain
period of time or not what you guys are
differing on is now how the left
basically will react so libby it's funny
to me in a weird way because the states
were already doing vastly different
things on abortion texas already had six
week limit florida which you guys know i
love and live in florida uh florida to
me did something super interesting only
three months ago the florida legislature
in this red right-wing state led by
don't say gay ron desantis passed a
15-week ban which doesn't even go into
effect until a couple weeks from now but
it wasn't even controversial here
meaning that a state that's mostly red
already was compromising on abortion so
is that the weird thing when it comes to
the outrage that we're about to see that
the states were already making up their
mind if you won an eight and a half
month abortion congratulations gavin
newsom will do it for you personally
well i think what we're going to see
this summer i think we're going to see
radical unhinged leftist feminists going
out there and trying to burn stuff down
i don't think it's going to matter to
them that you can get an abortion in
some states and not in other states
they're going to see this as a
racist white sitter cis heteronormative
assault on freedoms and trans rights and
women's rights and every kind of
conceivable thing that they can come up
with they've already threatened it we've
seen it with that group jane's revenge
the leaderless
pro-abortion militant activist group
that's you know
started fires and put graffiti all over
the place we've seen this and they are
poised and ready for another summer of
rage it doesn't matter to them that
states can do what they want it doesn't
matter to them on gun rights that now
you know states can't necessarily just
trounce all over to a rights they don't
care about that either they want what
they want they want to control other
people they want to control americans
they want to enact their bizarre ideas
of morality and these weird values that
don't value life and that are not
concerned with personal liberty or
freedom and that's what we're gonna see
we're gonna see crazy people running
around in the streets all summer
thinking that they have a right to
destroy things just because things
didn't go their way at the federal level